I was on the plane coming back, dude. I was on the plane coming back from, uh,
what do you call it? Where you know what, wherever the I was,
I died Daytona. I was on the plane coming back.
Hey man, look,
if you're a guy or a girl that talks too loud on the plane,
you deserve to not eat for three days or no,
you deserve to not eat the whole day. Three days is a lot, dude,
when you're on the plane, straight up, shut the up,
shut the up.
People are on the plane. Just like, well, you know, I talked to,
I talked to him the other day and he, you know, it's all, uh, you know, he said,
he'd have the reports in and you know, he did it and it's fine, but you know,
we'll get it. And it'll all be fine. But my, my issue is, if he's going,
gonna say, he's going to do something and he doesn't do it.
And everyone in the cabinet is just looking at each other,
like check out this
or, or even worse. It's a woman even worse.
It's a woman because they've got the voice. That's like, yeah, yeah.
You know, when a woman has a
[inaudible], it's like guys for some reason, guys, as annoying as guys will
just be like this, talking like this. But when women do it, it's just like
[inaudible].
And you're like, Oh, for sake is a dolphin in three F.
Yeah. So I talked to her and I and yen. Yeah.
I look at him, dude, guy or girl, I straight up look at him. I go like this.
Okay.
I do you think I'm joking? I look straight up.
I look at them and they're always in like a button down.
If you're a beat, fly comfy.
Who in a suit, you know guys relax, dude.
Yeah. So you know, and this guy was in front of me, dude, first of all,
he was 65. So you know how to live. Right.
You've had 65 years of doing it.
Don't know how to live.
And he's just talking to the flight attendant and the flight attendant is
talking back.
Like he doesn't have 150 cups to fill with ice.
And this guy's just yeah. Cause when I usually fly from, Oh dude,
really? Oh, when you, usually you usually,
When you usually fly,
you know how boring the sentence begins, the boring, how boring,
the sentences that begins with? Well, when I usually fly, Hey,
flying is boring.
That's why most people sleep during it.
Plain talkers dude,
dude. He was doing jokes.
And the flight attendant by the way was like love in it. They were the same age.
So they were like, it just drives me.
And it doesn't even have to be talking to you.
If you're talking loud around as practice,
keep touching your top lip to your bottom lip.
Practice that 30,000 feet in the air only
talk 5,000 feet above sea
level,
5,000 feet above sea level to sea level. That's where talking happens.
If you're above 5,000 feet
zip cake, or if you're on a tube, a long,
big tube,
that's the thing people will get at six o'clock in the morning,
there was another girl I was flying to wherever or,
or no eight Daytona. That's where I was flying to from or from Sacramento.
And she was just like in, in,
in line boarding and I was already sitting down and she was me at map me at map
map. And I looked up, dude,
me ma just loud as.
Just say quieter. We all hear you. If you're like this,
why do you have to meet up puppet dude?
And he was the guy, dude. And the guy was just
cause when I, when this, when I, I, the guy said I more than,
When I, he literally looked at the guy next to him and he said, Hey,
do you know the co pointed to his TV? And he said,
you know the code to get porn on this. Oh Jesus Christ, man.
You know what, dude, you have to fake laugh at it. And that was just the worst.
I'm in the, on behind him. Literally just like this.
I hope he looks back so I could just go, Hey dude,
when was your ninth birthday? Because Oh,
it already happened. Oh, then you know not to do this.
Hey man, what did you just get for your ninth birthday?
What do you mean? What did I just get? I'm 67.
Oh dude. My bad.
I thought you just had your ninth birthday because you're
doing what you're doing.
What kind of cake did you have? That's what, that's what I'm going to ask.
Anytime someone does talk loud, playing, talking from now on.
I'm going to turn to them and I'm going to say, Hey,
what kind of cake did you have?
Or Hey, how was your ninth birthday?
And when they look at me confused, I'm going to say, Oh,
dude, I'm sorry.
I didn't realize you're as old as you are because you're doing what you're
doing my bad.
Imagine if you really did that to someone,
how utterly mind would they be?
They wouldn't get it. First of all, but you would, and then they might get it.
Like they'd be on the rest of the flight. They'd just be like,
I think he was saying that I shouldn't be talking all loud
and maybe I should know that because I'm 65 and it's 6:00 AM and other people
are tired. Oh my God, plain talkers,
go to lunch, dude.